check out this week's must-see movie 100  are included back  Vin Diesel reprises his athletes turned  operative role in XXX the return of  xander cave  okay  pardon me sir I think you have the wrong  car three girls are kidnapped by a  schizophrenic in M night Shyamalan  thriller was not meant to touch you  we're meant for something horrible I  never seen a restaurant like this Allah  ordered ready in 30 seconds about 30  minutes the founder tells the story of  Ray Kroc the man behind McDonough even  is going to be enough for you probably  never hear this week's anticipation  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket  you  [Music]